[Music]
anybody hear about this uh
groundbreaking pig to human heart
transplant recently it was pretty fire
so groundbreaking never heard of it you
got a pig heart huh you're the pig guy
huh
god you're so insensitive man
you're really insensitive
hey make the big noise you [ __ ] big
heart guy
tell him a sad story add some stuff to
it no
it's not that sad
he's eight years old is it a human heart
that they grew on a pig or is it like
they just use the pig's heart they use
the pig heart you know how sometimes
they have like a human ear or some [ __ ]
or arm dangling off of a [ __ ] pig
this is medically groundbreaking but
then there's just one guy saying pig
heart friend said you got a pig dick too
let me see your tail idiot the guys look
like a really sad ted talk seems the
audience for roasting
i asked the guy who had to cut his own
arm off when he got stuck in a cliff
hey let's see the stub let's see the nap
just this classic heckler at ted talk
art [ __ ]
hey hey catch this nubby
sir sorry i can't catch it
oh he caught it with his other hand i
forgot he has the other hand
the dude starts a ted talk with a
stupid-ass joke like people say you are
what you eat and then steve's like [ __ ]
you
do you eat dicks are you a dick
he ran out of big material he's just
like
oh
[ __ ] this article dude this is good
okay just just to give some context um
uh in a medical first doctors had
transplanted a pig heart into a patient
in a last-ditch effort to save his life
in a maryland hospital uh while it's too
soon to know this the operation actually
did work so that's crazy that's the
context um this guy's brainstorming just
everyone so everyone knows he's
brainstorming he's coming up with big
[ __ ] right now
just like throw it out when you see it
but the point is this this pig heart
transplant had worked and uh they
recently found out that uh cocaine was
actually the secret ingredient and what
made that heart transplant work what
legalized cocaine yeah legalized cocaine
man legalized jk news is foreign what
does it do so uh doctor let me see if i
can pronounce this which i can't you can
dr muhammad mohuddin
xenotransplantation yeah that was
actually not about which refers to the
process of transferring an animal organ
into a human okay uh he spoke to a news
report about how this 57 year old
patient who became the host of a
genetically modified pig heart so it is
you know a little gmo there um they used
in terms of being able to transplant the
pig heart from overseas to america
because it was like manufactured
somewhere else so to speak that in order
to keep it uh in a healthy enough
condition and stabilize so that it would
be fine by the time it got to the
patient they had to use cocaine
to keep it like beating wow they just
have cocaine at the hospital well they
don't call it cocaine right they've had
like the active ingredient of it
you think they [ __ ] like
just sprinkle a little cocaine on top
like
it's like sugar
it's like the parmesan thing yeah
a little more cocaine yeah tell me one
tell me what yeah we're going
um
[Laughter]
look so we've prepared some rails for
you
and um
so here you tell me when yeah tell me
when you're just putting it on a big
glass mirror so they transported the
heart as by itself right not they didn't
give coke to a pig
that would be cool that's crazy
so the heart was developed by lab
company that's now just
two
lines yo you think someone like
went there with like just held the
[ __ ] box of heart and then and then
flew with it don't they keep it in the
cooler as hell dude that's the first
time in history you really think they're
just sitting on a plane first class
holding a box or is it a [ __ ]
handcuffed to a briefcase
this is medical code this is medical how
did they travel with cocaine the heart
was developed by lab company revivacore
tweaked so that the dna would be more
amenable to a human host than fortified
with the party drug by swedish medical
tech company ex vivo before traveling to
the us so usually transplant organs
originate from a much shorter distance
as they deteriorate within a few hours
outside of the body but they explained
that cocaine was used in a mixture among
hormones including cortisol and
adrenaline that keep the live tissue
from spoiling during its long journey
overseas to maryland so coke is bad i
guess huh but it can do that
are you kidding me i love that whoever
he's talking to
coke is bad everyone says that it can do
that i think coke is fine obviously the
proprietary solution raised flags with
drug enforcement officials in the u.s
where cocaine has never before been used
in this setting
so the cocaine name pops out because
everybody thinks oh my god what is
cocaine doing in here says the doctor
but obviously it was used in a medical
way in order to keep the heart amenable
do they also have trance playing
non-stop until they got there
they got old mario
the heart has ears on it they can hear
the music the vibrations move the person
transported to steve aoki
so this doctor said uh when we were not
using the solution i like how it's
called the solution instead of cocaine
uh we were getting failures within 48
hours but when we started using this and
infusing the heart with the solution the
heart became well preserved and started
beating very well whoa that's dope
that's cool if you got heart problems
man okay
you pass out your heart stops spreading
okay not it dude i mean you know like
what was that denzel washington movie
where he's a [ __ ] uh equalizer dude
no not that one hey was it flight flight
remember memory
drinks all the alcohol in the hotel and
then and then you know
yeah no no uh to go to court oh yeah
spoiler alert that's where he goes
[ __ ]
oh where he plays that black guy oh
didn't he [ __ ] did he land the plane
upside down that's the movie yeah yeah
now we're going backwards but he's
trying to talk about the end of him
we're talking about the end of the movie
that's medicinal where he has to use the
coke i'm over it that's where he says
that little girl i know i know that
movie he saves that little girl
he trains himself for her yeah
oh yeah dakota fanny and then he says
[ __ ]
he looks in the camera and it goes he
goes
this is a trading day [ __ ]
that was the movie that was the [ __ ]
movie he breaks he breaks the fourth
wall there's a training time
and he said that to the titans
remember he went to ryan gosling looked
him in the [ __ ] eye and he said what
was the line
[ __ ]
training game [ __ ] remember your
titans
i hate the idea of denzel breaking the
fourth wall in every move he's like one
of the greatest actors ever
there's no movie has ever been where you
could possibly break the fourth but he
does always say though he doesn't always
say the title of the movie he always
says training day in every movie he said
equalizer two in the second one he said
equalizer because you know me i'm a real
american gangster
[Laughter]
and john q he said it too
it's his name they were like you're not
gonna you're not gonna treat my son what
is this training day [ __ ]
everybody's moving yeah that wasn't john
q remember the time that's in his writer
actually yeah people don't know that
it's writer
i gotta say this like
every movie or he won't do it his
director is like [ __ ] okay
that's probably real for samuel jackson
that's true who's that
[Laughter]
who
we're talking denzel [ __ ]
washington man i like it the game is no
matter what anthony says we just saw
[ __ ] on it
i like that i like it even ryan's on
board
ryan's known anthony longer than anybody
ryan's not even supposed to be here
today [ __ ] seven seats like what the
[ __ ] are you not to you're not supposed
to be here they [ __ ] read the email i
have the same name as the guy that
[ __ ] texts the whole thing so i
always read it i go oh i'm here it's
true
oh that's what happened
i was wondering
so many people this is a professional
environment where the bosses always know
what the [ __ ] is going on
on camera like that's what happened just
got this much a chemistry oh oh my god
i kind of like that three seats over
there though it's pretty fire yeah
that's pretty cool yeah geo there and
now we have ryan
on a day he's supposed to tech today
yeah sorry guys
more denzel lines please
oh i don't know another
that's all
wait what a recent denzel movie tragedy
of macbeth you got sir oh what is that
it's on apple dude anthony lee you're a
big denzel washington fan that was
[ __ ] sick it wasn't moving before
that before that probably equalizer too
yeah probably there's two of those
pretty little things that movie on hbo
max wasn't he in that
oh he was the movie the movie was okay
that movie was okay because he doesn't
say the line he doesn't say it online
bro he didn't say pretty flowers
[ __ ]
what's the name
sam jackson says [ __ ] literally
everything i like how he's true it's
about it's not even about this well
who's that
that's that's why i'm like i like the
idea if someone's never heard of sam i
know right but thinks denzel says
everything he says
we're right there with you very complex
that
so no one else done this pig heart thing
what does denzel think about this
[Music]
you